there's an alligator and Alba chimera
while you're doing something with the
ally you have to do the play-by-play on
this forest Alvin so they had to fool
the alligators like the pit - that one
specifically had like I had to give him
a shower or something so they duct-tape
a big duct tape his mouth and you know
he trusts that tape though until it is
it taped pretty good that's a problem I
won't be there
well hey Alvin it's great seeing you
buddy I remember we had you a couple
years ago after you were named the NFC
Offensive Rookie of the Year I actually
write at the time that that that award
was being given what kind of a journeys
have been for you so far yeah it's been
great you know I'm trying to just keep
it going you know blessed to be winning
you know three winning seasons in my
first three seasons in the NFL three Pro
Bowls you know great teammates great
coaches you know just blessed to be in
the position I'm in what what is it
about the organization that's special to
you I mean a got a legendary coach a
legendary quarterback I mean it's as
simple as that well what is it to you
that you just look at it where you guys
have walked you know you're walked in
you're so relevant all the time and is
that I mean I think it's just the the
the camaraderie in the locker room like
the culture we've created I mean it's
just like a family environment you know
I mean I don't think guys are are
dreading going to work every day I think
we all want to come to work we all want
to get better we want to be around each
other I mean and that helps that much
more on Sundays and Mondays and
Thursdays when we're out there playing
you know I think it's like just a a
certain level of trust like within
within our locker room and on that field
that you know allows us to be a good
year in a year Sean talked about it I
know last year a little bit where like
he brought in like the mascots right
like what was like the theme this year
that there's anything that he did crazy
for the meeting Wednesday
week to keep everybody loose I'm trying
to think what he did one one week he
brought he he brought in some fish
I forgot what team we beat and he was
throwing dead fish in the in the TV room
yeah because of their fish market when
we keep brought in hang up forgot I mean
he always find something like whoever
were playing he seems crazy awesome I'm
[ __ ] my hip bone fit like he comes in
he's this I get in the team meeting room
he smelled like fish were like slippery
we got some highlights of that game
where you guys went up there took care
of the seniors take a look at the
monitor and we'll see a little Alvin
Camaro doing what album premier does
steady breeze green the little screen
man this is where your special did it's
rare season from that's a tough place to
play admit yes what is that three jet
slow screen right what is that 22 cell
across screen right to eight yeah okay
all right the MA uh uh you know what I
mean you're one of the best in football
dual threat running backs everything you
got great power again I don't mean this
like to be offensive it seemed like it
was a year where statistically and you
just didn't get as many touches or have
to as many highlight plays yeah you know
it's just one of those years trying to
kind of be able to injury early in the
season right you know just you know it
is what it is sometimes that happens you
know you just gotta fight adversity um
and so I did try to try to do that to
the best of my ability you know I was
coming
um was coming in to form a little bit
towards the end of the season yeah you
were yeah sorry
but you know it is what it is that's
challenge you never truly get the chance
to heal you can't just shut it down
you're competitive you want to keep
going so you'll go at eighty percent
eighty five is that because you want to
because that's what you do yeah but and
and you know from and people say always
number they like you the fantasy
football Corrado's number yeah because
he's injured
really already get into like trying to
defend myself with that because you know
they're just what we will be watching
for fantasy so right it is what it is
but you know I mean it's real-life
things going on it's guys playing
injured this guy's playing with you know
things going on with them it you know
circumstances that you know a fan might
not see that's going on but you know so
you can't blame him yeah you guys got
some good quarterbacks yeah yeah and and
I try to figure out how we're gonna I
don't think all three we're coming back
I don't know what's going on well you
have a hunch on whether or not I know
but it's gonna be a little more yeah now
you know um you know Drew's had a great
career I think everybody that's what
everybody's wondering now like what
you're gonna do and I always say it like
I think he can play as long as he wants
to Teddy you know we saw what he did
when he came in when yeah and he when he
had to answer the call and then taste
some you know he'd like the jack of all
trades like he does it also is he a
freak or what yeah I mean like a freak
like true for real right right not yes
it worked hard it yeah I mean he works
his tail off so you know I guess he
deserves everything he gets so you know
370 dues and you know we'll see how it
sit so um you guys the year ends up
being disappointing because I know you
wanted to be here in the Superbowl you
guys got screwed over last year and we
know that you had the Minneapolis
miracle before that I kind of like just
want to dive into the psychological
aspect of like week 17 49ers Seahawks
right you're probably watching the game
probably going Russell Wilson's gonna go
down here and score touchdown that we're
gonna be first round by home field
advantage everything like that do you
think that like played into the letdown
the next week did you notice that that
was in the locker room that week like
people go man we were this close to
being I don't think it really was girl I
mean Sean said it three weeks like
before they I mean he was telling us he
was like when that we went out and we're
gonna we're gonna have the first see you
know we're not we're gonna first see you
so guys were like alright we just gotta
we focus on us I mean we always do that
we focus on what we got yeah right
whatever happens happens you know
usually we want to control our own
destiny of course but you know when you
have to wait on the team to lose or team
to do this it seemed to do that you know
it's like you kind of playing with yeah
yeah I didn't really I wasn't really too
locked into that I'm like menace
whatever right you'll just play
whoever's out there I just want to win
where we got a win-win the rest of our
games and handle it was next Alvin you
guys played the 49ers a great game one
of the best games of the regular season
who is the guy on that 49ers defense
you're always keeping your eye on to
make sure you know if he's coming you
you two you watch that boy BOCES I mean
you watch this film it's like he's
disruptive right I mean they got I mean
Nate not to take away any credit from
the rest of those guys but to come in
you like and have a year he's having
like this is like he's one of the better
defensive players in all football right
he is as a rookie I mean to come in and
do that I mean I'm just thinking about
in my rookie year and just like you know
just adjusting to the league and no not
I mean he hit his stride and he stopped
being slowed down what was the biggest
adjustment for you I think just the
length of the season like you know it's
like you've got to find a second and
third and fourth win like a rookie year
because you go from combine the probated
OTA is the mini camps are like you don't
have any break at uh you know so they're
working on the new labor deal that's
gonna be based on 17 games they get it
done and and I think guys are all over
the map on whether they want to add that
extra regular-season game your thoughts
on that it was like a huge jump in your
salary right like what how because I
think one more check and just one more
track like the NFL is gonna have to make
that extra game count like three games
something like that right in my opinion
yeah I mean I'm we're we all make the
rules
we are players show here so we're we
know the owners are rich we already know
that they don't need any more money we'd
like to see it going to the players
hands so yeah so yeah it's got to make a
count for you got to you definitely
gotta count what do you feel like when
the season's over like explain to people
out there what it's like to be an NFL
running back and now okay my body's been
beat to crap and now I got a heal season
over it's like and you you start to like
I think you really start to think of
like what you really just did so not
just it's not just that 16 games it's
like all right we had preseason games
yeah
camp that we just went through we had
OTA is he was training like it's a whole
like snowball effect of you know all
that physical work that you
just put in and it's like throughout the
season sometimes you don't realize how
hurt you are how tired you are you just
going going going like when the season
ends like I think like the next two
three days I was like knocked out like
just sleep like because my body was like
okay I can finally relax like I'm not
ready like yeah I got a place Sunday I
got to play mother I got to get ready
ready Moto's like oh I'm done I'll just
passed out like I was tired like I'm
starting to feel everything is hurt just
whatever you just got it you just got to
find a way to recharge and and you know
get back right Alvin how long does it
take after that last game for you to
begin to feel right again as far as just
over like like health like a good
workout and I'm good and I'm healthy I
mean it I think everybody differs me I
come out I try to take a good amount of
time off just a lot you know I can feel
everything like you know cause like I
said during the season you might not
feel everything that's that's really
going on with you till you kind of sit
down for a second you like oh that my
shoulder or I knew your market or ankle
leg right you kind of just got to sit
back and like you know go do your go do
your physical and check on everything
and make sure everything's good and just
take some time to kind of like let
everything calm down rest a little bit
and you know then you could pick back up
with your training whenever one thing I
love about Super Bowl week it's Old
Spice time it's what the t-shirt has
been upgraded it is Arthur shader ray
it's good I like and I'm an Old Spice
guy I like this oh look at you you got
notes and everything you know not as
low-key on the field but off the field
I'm pretty low-key um yeah you know I
like clean smells nice scent so I'm with
you know Old Spice has launched a new
line it's ultra smooth and this is
antiperspirant from that line and this
is like real dude yeah I want to smell
it
because I'm an Old Spice guy and I'm not
even buying I might throw this
underneath my armpit right now just to
make sure I'm good too you know what
you're doing there top off yeah it does
smell good
I am BAM yeah I've been using Old Spice
my whole life and I've got one of the
t-shirts I got to upgrade yeah you got
free crap already you don't show up it's
great talking to you buddy and it's
great seeing you as always
congratulations on the career so far we
look forward to rootin for you yeah in
2020 and Beyond know that you like
watches though I have them yet
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports